ASSEMBLY MILITARY AND VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO
ORDER AND WE WILL BE STARTING
AS A SUB COMMITTEE- WELCOME TO
THE HEARING WHETHER YOU ARE
HERE IN PERSON WATCHING
VIRTUALLY ARE ON THE PHONE
LINES- WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
JOIN US FIRST A NOTE AND I'M
SURE ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE VERY HAPPY TO HEAR THIS-
THE AUTHOR OF THE- FIRST ITEM
IN THE FILES SB FORTY THREE HAS
WITHDRAWN THE BILL FROM THE
HEARING. AND SO WE WILL PRESENT
BEGIN- BILL PRESENTATIONS WITH
FILE ITEM TO BEFORE I GET WELL-
BEFORE THAT'LL GO OVER SOME KEY
ELEMENTS WE HAVE A STRICT MASC
REQUIREMENT FOR EVERYBODY IN
ATTENDANCE AND ALL WHO ARE IN
THE CAPITAL'S COMMON AREAS AND
WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR A WITNESS CEREMONY-
TESTIMONY TODAY IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND. WHEN I
CALL FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE IN ADDITION WILL BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE IT
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE WILL ALSO BE USING AN
AT&T MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL
THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY SO
I'M ASKING EVERYBODY TO PLEASE
BE PATIENT ARE ALSO REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS AVAILABLE ON
THE NORTH STEPS OF THE CAPITOL.
THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
1-877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO OH TWO AGAIN THAT
NUMBER IS 1-877-692-8957 YOU'LL
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY MILITARY AND VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR MONITOR
SCREEN IF YOU PLAN ON CALLING
IN PLEASE DO SO- AS THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL YOU ARE TESTIFYING
IN ITS BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ABOUT HOW. THE
BILL COULD BE PLACED INTO
WHETHER- YOU ARE- INTO. OR
OPPOSE A BILL IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE OUT
DISTORTION. ALSO PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE THE
LEAD THAT WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL YOU WILL REMAIN ON THE
LIVE LINE IT WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
TO SPEAK. PLEASE NOTE THAT WE
ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. AND WE DO HAVE- SOME
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THAT HAS THAT
BEEN PASSED AROUND READY OKAY-
ADDITIONALLY PLEASE NOTE THAT
THE GUIDELINES FOR TODAY'S FOR
A BILLS HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE TO ALLOW TESTIMONY
FROM THE TO LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND TO IN OPPOSITION
AND THEY CAN SPEAK FOR NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES TOTAL
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND ENTITIES
THAT ARE NEITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WILL BE. ALLOWED TO
GIVE TESTIMONY FOR NO MORE THAN
ONE MINUTE WHEN I CALL THEM IF
THE MEASURE HAS MORE THAN TWO
ENTITIES IN THAT CATEGORY ONLY
TWO WILL BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK
FOR ONE MINUTE EACH WHEN CALLED
UPON BY THE EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR REMARKS YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND STANCE ON
A MEASURE THAT IS PRESENTLY
BEING. DEBATED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND
PARTICIPATION. BEFORE WE- OF
NOW DO WE HAVE. NOW WE'RE
WAITING FOR A COUPLE OF OTHER
MEMBERS SO- WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO VOTE ON CONSENT BUT
LET ME TELL YOU THE BILLS THAT
ARE ON CONSENT IT'S SB THREE
FIVE TWO EGGMAN. I DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SB THREE NINE
NINE I'M BURKE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SB FOUR NINE
EIGHT I'M BURKE TO PASS A
ROUTE- RECOMMEND TO- CONSENTS-
SB SIX FOURTEEN ARE TO LEAD A
DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
RECOMMENDED TO CONSENT. AS J.
R. THREE ARCHULETA BE ADOPTED
RECOMMENDED TO CONSENT AND SB
SIX SIX ONE NEWMAN DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMENDED. TO
CONSENT. ALL RIGHT- AND WE DO
HAVE A SIX MEMBERS HERE SO DO I
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND ON THE
CONSENT. IN OKAY OF AND PRIVATE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON CONSENT SEVEN THREE FIVE
SORRY WE FIRST HAVE TO DO A
ROLL CALL. IRWIN HERE. VOEPEL
BOERNER HORVATH. DALY YOUR
FRAZIER MATHIS YOUR MURATSUCHI
PETRIE-NORRIS RAMOS. SALAS
SMITH. ALL RIGHT AND THEN WE
WILL MOVE- TO BE CONSECTETUER.
ON CONSENT SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTY TWO BY EGGMAN
RECOMMENDATION IS DUE PASSED
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMEND
CONSENT SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY NINE UMBERG TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMEND
CONSENT. SENATE BILL FOUR
NINETY EIGHT UMBERG DO PASS
RECOMMEND CONSENT SENATE BILL
SIX FOURTEEN ARCHULETA TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMEND
CONSENT S. U. R. THREE
ARCHULETA BE ADOPTED RECOMMEND
CONSENT. SENATE BILL SIX SIX
ONE NEWMAN TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMENDED KIT
TO CONSENT MOVED BY FRAZIER
SECOND MATHIS. IRWIN I- WHEN I
VOEPEL VOEPEL HI
BOERNER HORVATH. DALY DALY AYE
FRAZIER FRAZIER HI MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MATTEUCCI
PETRIE-NORRIS RAMOS SALAS SMITH
SMITH HI. ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD
AND NOW WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
SB THREE FORTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
GROWTH AND- THIS WILL BE
PRESENTED BY SENATOR RALPH ON
HER BEHALF WHEN YOU ARE READY.
SENATOR GOOD AFTERNOON AND THE
PLEASE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- APPRECIATE YOU
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ON
BEHALF OF CENTER GROVE THE BILL
REQUIRES CALVET PRIOR TO
CLOSING CALIFORNIA VETERANS
HOME TO ESTABLISH A TASK FORCE
TO ANALYZE THE COST BENEFIT THE
COMMUNITY IMPACT AND REVIEW THE
COMMUNITY INPUT REGARDING THE
CLOSURE. PER THE BILL THE TASK
FORCE MUST CONSIST OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT ELECTED OFFICIALS
FROM THE COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
AND STAFF OF THE HOME. AS WELL
AS LOCAL VETERANS GROUP GROUPS.
UPON THE REVIEW COMPLETION THE
TASK FORCE IS REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AND REPORT EFFORTS
TO ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION IN
COMMUNITY MEETINGS RELATED TO
THE PROPOSED CLOSURE THE INTENT
IS TO ESTABLISH A PROCESS. THE
BILL TRANSPARENCY INTO PROPOSED
VETERANS HOME CLOSURES AND
ALLOW FOR PUBLIC INPUT SO THE
DEPARTMENT CAN. MAKE CONSIDER
THE IMPLICATIONS OF SUCH ACTION
JOINING ME TODAY IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING IS. CIMBRIAN
COUNTY SUPERVISOR DON ROWE
THIRD DISTRICT SUPERVISOR TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
AND- DO WE HAVE SUPERVISOR DON
ROWE ON THE LINE. SUPERVISOR
ROBIE'S PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. I DO NOT SEE HIM
CURRENTLY ON THE PHONE LINES.
ALRIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ON THE
PHONE LINE IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE TO
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GIVE THEIR LINE NUMBERS. IS ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT.
WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF FOUR FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE FOUR FOUR SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ACTUALLY
SUPERVISOR DON ROW I WAS UNABLE
TO BE HEARD EARLIER IS IT STILL
POSSIBLE TO PROVIDE MY
TESTIMONY YES PLEASE. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE ONE WOMAN
OR ONE OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO START BY
THANKING EACH OF YOU FOR YOUR
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT. PART OF
OUR CALIFORNIA VETERANS MY NAME
IS DON ROW AND I SERVICE THE
THIRD DISTRICT SUPERVISOR FOR
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY. MY
DISTRICT INCLUDES THE CITY OF
BARSTOW AND THE VETERANS HOME.
I'M A VERY SYMPATHETIC AND
INTERESTED- PERSON WHEN IT
COMES TO VETERAN ISSUES AS I AM
A GOLD STAR WIFE MY LATE
HUSBAND WAS KILLED IN COMBAT IN
IRAQ IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR.
SO I UNDERSTAND FIRST HAND WHAT
OUR SERVICE MEMBERS SACRIFICE
FOR OUR FREEDOMS. LAST YEAR I
WAS APPALLED TO LEARN OF THE
PROPOSED CLOSURE OF THE BARSTOW
VETERANS HOME AS A METHOD TO
SOLVE THE STATE'S BUDGET
DEFICIT. CLOSING THE HOME WOULD
HAVE DISPLACED NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED VETERANS AND REQUIRED
MOST IF NOT ALL TO RELOCATE TO
OTHER VETERANS HOMES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. YOU CAN IMAGINE
THERE WAS AN IMMEDIATE
OUTPOURING OF OPPOSITION TO THE
VETERANS GROUPS. COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND LOCAL ELECTED
LEADER LOCAL ELECTED LEADERS
LIKE MYSELF. WE WERE FRUSTRATED
TO DISCOVER THAT THERE WASN'T A
FORMAL PROCESS FOR COMMUNITIES
AFFECTED BY PROPOSED CLOSURES
TO WEIGH IN. VETERANS HOMES ARE
AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE AND
IT WAS CLEAR THAT THERE NEEDED
TO BE MORE TRANSPARENT PROCESS
THAT PROVIDED AMPLE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PUBLIC INPUT. THIS IS WHY I
COMMEND SENATOR GROW FOR
INTRODUCING SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY EIGHT. THIS MEASURE
ESTABLISHES A PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION PROCESS FOR
PROPOSED VETERANS HOME
CLOSURES. AND GIVES A STRONGER
VOICE TO VETERANS AT RISK OF
LOSING THE BENEFIT THAT THEY
RIGHTFULLY EARNED ON THE
BATTLEFIELD. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF SB THREE FORTY EIGHT AND I
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SUPERVISOR ROW AND I THINK WE
HAVE ONE MORE WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. YES AND THAT'LL COME
FROM THE LINE OF. FOUR FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THIS IS DANA NICOLE WITH
MARINA GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMVETS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COMMANDER VETERANS COUNCIL AN
UMBRELLA ASSOCIATION OF OVER
TWENTY VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FORTY EIGHT. THE
MEMBERS OF THE BAR STYLE HOME
AND THE PUBLIC MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT WAS NOT THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE VETERANS FOR
THE STATE TO MAKE SUCH A
DECISION WITHOUT INPUT FROM ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE
NO OF A OPPOSITION REGISTERED
TO- FOR LEAD WITNESSES SO ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES ON THE LINE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FORTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THAT'S THE ONE THAT
THEN ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION.
AND WE HAVE NOT A POSITION TO
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN THAT SHAME ON THE
CHAMBER FLOOR OR IN THE GALLERY.
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY AND- DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION ON AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. NOPE IT
APPEARS NOTS- ARE THERE ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. WITH THE BILL THANKS
ALL RIGHT FIVE FIVE I THINK WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS REQUEST
FROM RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ALL RIGHT SENATOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK
THAT TRANSPARENCY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A ADEQUATE
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IS ALWAYS
A GOOD THING THE HOME SYSTEM
MAY REQUIRE CHANGES IN THE
OTHER CONFIGURATION INCLUDING
LOCATION CARE LEVELS IN ORDER
TO BETTER SERVE THE FUTURE
NEEDS OF VETERANS. BUT A SOUND
PROPOSAL SHOULD BE ABLE TO PASS
MUSTER SO THIS BILL ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION AND IF I
CAN HAVE- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY EIGHT BY GROWTH BY MATHIS
SECOND FRAZIER MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN
HI- IRWIN I VOEPEL. PATEL I.
BOERNER HORVATH DALY. DALY AYE
FRAZIER. FRAZIER II MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MURATSUCHI WE'RE TO
GI PETRIE-NORRIS RAMOS RAMOS HI
SALAS SMITH SMITH HI. EIGHT ALL
RIGHT THAT BUILDS OUT THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU. AND WE ARE
WAITING- CURRENTLY FOR SENATOR-
BURKE SO NOT EVERYBODY WAS HERE
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR COULD
WE GO THROUGH AND- CHECK WITH
THE- CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THEM
ON CONSENT. BOERNER HORVATH
MURATSUCHI WE'RE TO GI
PETRIE-NORRIS RAMOS RAMOS AYE
SALAS. THANK YOU.
FOR YEAH
THAT'S WHAT IT. IRATE MOVE THE
BUILD. YOUR CALL CENTER. IRATE-
SO AGAIN WE ARE GOING TO BE
HEARING SB SIX SIX FIVE BY
SENATOR- BURKE A SENATOR WHEN
YOU ARE READY PLEASE PROCEED-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- RESHAPE
YOUR WORK AND THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK ON THIS BILL- THIS BILL
THAT THAT YOU HAVE SEEN BEFORE
MOST OF YOU SEEN BEFORE-
HOWEVER THE BILLION SAW BEFORE.
WAS MUCH BROADER THIS BILL- HAS
CERTAIN OTHER LIMITATIONS FOR
EXAMPLE SUNSET CLAUSE ALSO WITH
RESPECT TO- THOSE MILITARY
MEMBERS THAT WERE DISCHARGED
BECAUSE OF THEIR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. THEY'LL BE TREATED
JUST AS ANY OTHER VETERAN UNDER
UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL VERSION AYE VOTE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SENATOR- BURKE. AND WE HAVE A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT J. R. WILSON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
MATTERS COUNCIL AND DISABLED
AMERICAN VETERANS MISTER WILSON
ARE YOU READY. OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE IN THE
QUEUE. I DO NOT SEE MUCH OF
OFTEN DAHLE THEN IT WAS TIME.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
QUEUE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE FOUR LINES IN QUEUE LINES
FOR SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NOT IN TURN MEMBERS MADISON
VALLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN RED CROSS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FOR
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS DANA WITH RAYMOND
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
LEGION AND AMVETS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY VETERAN
SERVICE OFFICERS CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDER VETERANS
COUNCIL MILITARY OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA IN THE
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA IN
SUPPORT AND SB SIX SIX FIVE.
THE YOUNG VETERANS COMMITTEE
EARLY ADULT YEARS TO DEFENDING
OUR NATION'S FREEDOMS HOWEVER
BY OING SO THEY ARE AT A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE WHEN
SEEKING A CAREER AFTER THEIR
ENLISTMENT. MANY EMPLOYERS KNOW
THIS I DON'T WANT TO HELP.
VETERANS COME FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE THE MILITARY WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST LARGE ORGANIZATIONS
TO RACIALLY INTEGRATE. THIS
BILL WILL HELP ALL VETERANS WHO
SEEK JOBS THAT UTILIZES BENEFIT
ACCORDING TO THE DISABLED
VETERANS OF AMERICA. TODAY
WOMEN ARE SERVING IN GREATER
NUMBERS OF U. S. MILITARY MAKE
UP 20% OF NEW RECRUITS 16% OF
PERSONNEL SERVING ON ACTIVE
DUTY IN 19% OF THE NATIONAL
GUARD AND RESERVE FORCES. THESE
NUMBERS ARE GROWING EVERY DAY
O THIS BENEFITS CONFERRED BY
SB SIX SIX FIVE WILL. WILL
HELP. A LOT OF OUR YOUTH. GET
BACK INTO THE WORKFORCE AND
BUILD SUCCESSFUL CAREERS THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FIVE FOUR SIXTY POINT.
RIGHT. FOR SIX. NINE FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FOUR FIVE EIGHT. I'M JUST
TRYING IN OPPOSITION. NINE FOUR
FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FOUR FIVE SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR WHEN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KELLY
MAY DOUGLAS AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
NOW WE HAVE THE LEAD THAT
WITNESS FOR THE OPPOSITION I
KEVIN BAKER FOR THE ACLU.
MISTER BAKER AND. I DO NOT SEE
MISTER BAKER LINE DIAL THEM
ALRIGHT WE HAVE SOME OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR MR BAKER.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND FOR SIXTEEN CLEAN
SCHOOL. THANKS FOR. ALL YOUR.
FINE FOUR FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KEVIN BAKER THE MARKET SOME OF
THE VIRGINIA ALSO TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF COALITION OF CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS REFLECTED
IN THE COMMITTEE PALACES. THEY
TELL YOU IN THE OPEN IN
OPPOSITION A LOT OF ACTIVITY ON
BEHALF OF VETERANS THE MANY.
AND WE APPLAUDED GO ABOVE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
VETERANS. WE ARE NOT A TO THE
VERY VOTER. OF THIS BILL AND WE
WOULD BE VERY HAPPY TO SEE IT
MOVE FORWARD. WITH ONE SMALL
BUT IMPORTANT CHANGE. WHICH IS
TO PRESERVE LONGSTANDING
PROTECTIONS AGAINST UNLAWFUL
DISCRIMINATION. CALIFORNIA HAD
MULTIPLE. OPTIONS FOR MANY
DECADES WITHOUT EXCEPTION. AND
THERE IS NO NEED TO LIMIT THEM
NOW. IT IS PERFECTLY POSSIBLE
TO ALLOW PRIVATE EMPLOYERS TO
HAVE VETERANS PERKINS POLICIES
WITHOUT DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
OTHERS. TWO GOALS DO NOT NEED
TO BE IN CONFLICT. EXCEPT AT
THE OFFICE UNFORTUNATELY
WRITTEN A BILL THAT WAY. HE DID
NOT ALL DR TO PRACTICE
DISCRIMINATION IN THEIR NAME.
IT IS REGRETTABLE THIS MEASURE
UNNECESSARILY ASKS YOU TO DO
SO. WE COULD HAVE BETTERMENT
PROVINCES AND STILL MAINTAIN A
LONGSTANDING CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS.
IF YOU CHOOSE TO DO SO WE ASK
THAT YOU RESPECT YOUR
COMMITMENT TO BOTH VETERANS AND
CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS MEDINA WE
HAVE A QUESTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BAKER AND YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER. WASN'T THERE
ONE MORE WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
NOW I CURRENTLY HAVE NO LINES
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON THE CHAMBER FLOOR
OR IN THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
HEARING THAT OKAY I WILL OPEN
IT UP FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE THIS RARE
SUTRI. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR FOR A BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I APOLOGIZE FOR. NOT
HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO-
ENGAGED TO REACH OUT TO YOU
EARLIER TO. RAISE THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE JUST RAISED BY THE
ACLU- IT SEEMS THAT- THAT- I
KNOW THAT YOU APPRECIATE THIS
DILEMMA FOR MANY OF US-
INCLUDING I'M SURE YOURSELF IN
WANTING TO SHOW OUR SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATION RESPECT FOR
VETERANS WITH THIS VOLUNTARY
VETERANS HIRING PREFERENCE.
WELL WITHOUT- COMPROMISING THE-
DISCRIMINATION PROTECTIONS- FOR
OTHER PROTECTED GROUPS CAN YOU
RESPOND TO BE OF THE QUESTION
RAISED BY THE ACLU- YOU KNOW
WHY WE CANNOT TO. WHY THIS BILL
CANNOT MAKE IT CLEAR THAT-
THAT- WE CAN SUPPORT VOLUNTARY
HIRING PREFERENCES WHILE ALSO
MAKING CLEAR THAT DISPARATE
IMPACT DISCRIMINATION IS STILL
PROHIBITED- SURE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- MURATSUCHI SO
I SHOULD MAKE IT CLEAR IN THE
OPENING THAT THAT WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT PROVIDES THE
SAME KINDS ALTHOUGH EVEN MORE
CONSTRAINED OF VETERANS
PREFERENCES THAT EXISTS IN ALL
FIFTY STATES AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF
GOVERNMENTAL HIRING. ALSO
PROVIDES SOMETHING THAT'S EVEN
MORE CONSTRAINED THAT WHAT
EXIST IN THIRTY NINE OTHER
STATES- AND I APPRECIATE MR
BAKERIES RAISE CONCERNS AND-
IMPROVE THE BILL SO FOR EXAMPLE
AS I MENTIONED THE OPENING.
THAT ANYONE WHO WAS DISCHARGED
UNDER THE- PROVISIONS THAT
PROVIDED FOR DISCHARGE OF
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE OF THEIR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION THAT THAT
THEY WOULD BE TREATED AS A
VETERAN FOR ALL PURPOSES. UNDER
THIS BILL SO. THE CONCERN I
THINK OF THE ACLU IS IT HAS A
DISPARATE IMPACT IN OTHER WORDS
OF THE UNIVERSE OF VETERANS IS.
A SIGNIFICANTLY MORE MALE AND
HIS FEMALE- AND THERE HAVE BEEN
PAST DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES
OF THE MILITARY ONE THE MOST
EGREGIOUS WAS DISCRIMINATING
BASED ON SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR
YOUR- GENDER UP AFFIRMATION
THAT KIND OF THING. BOB THAT'S
NOT THE DEPARTMENT DEFENSE
TODAY BUT THE QUESTION IS DO WE
BASICALLY NOT PROVIDE BUT FIFTY
STATES ARE PROVIDING BECAUSE
THE PAST DISCRIMINATION
MILITARY I THINK NOT I MEAN I
THINK THE REASON PEOPLE THAT
THEY CAN DISAGREE. AND IT DOES
HAVE A DISPARATE IMPACT IT HAS
A DISK IT IS. GOING TO
DISCREETLY IMPACTED TINO'S
BECAUSE LATINOS FORM A GREATER
PORTION OF THE MILITARY THAN
THEY DO THE GENERAL POPULATION
THE SAME THING WITH AFRICAN
AMERICANS IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
DISPARATE IMPACT BECAUSE
AFRICAN AMERICANS COMPRISE A
LARGER PORTION MILITARY THAN
THE GENERAL POPULATION. SO AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT- THERE'S AN
ISSUE CONCERNING THE UNIVERSE.
OF POTENTIAL APPLICANTS- A
SKEWS MALE IT DOES SKEW MALE
IT'S CHANGING AS WAS POINTED
OUT WHEN I FIRST JOINED THE
MILITARY WAS NOT. 8% FEMALE
NOW- IT'S 20% THE RECRUITS AND
SO- WHAT THIS DOES IS IT DOES
IT RECOGNIZE THE SERVICE ALSO
PROVIDES EMPLOYERS THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE IN THE
GOVERNMENT HAVE. TO UTILIZE THE
SKILLS ARE DEVELOPED IN THE
MILITARY BY MILITARY PERSONNEL
GOVERNMENT HAS THAT.
OPPORTUNITY PRIVATE SECTOR
SHOULD AS WELL. OKAY SO- YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE SAYING THAT- THE
REASON WHY THIS BILL CAN NOT
EXPLICITLY PROHIBIT DISPARATE
IMPACT DISCRIMINATION IS
BECAUSE YOU'RE A KNOWLEDGE
THING THAT IT WOULD LEAD TO. A
DESPERATE IMPACT. FOR OVER
REPRESENTED GROUPS LIKE BLACKS
AND LATINOS IF WE ARE GOING TO
WAIT. I MEAN I SUPPOSE IF
YOU'RE GOING TO APPLY THIS
PRINCIPLE YOU WOULD SAY THAT WE
SHOULD REVOKE THE PREFERENCE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR FIRST STATE
EMPLOYEES WAS REVOKED THE OTHER
PREFERENCES- IF WE'RE GOING TO
WAIT UNTIL THERE'S FIFTY
PERCENT. FEMALE AND 50% MALES
WHO ARE IN THE UNIVERSE OF
VETERANS IT WILL NOT BE IN MY
LIFETIME I GUESS IT WON'T BE IN
ANY OF OUR LIFETIMES SO THE
QUESTION IS SO EIGHT EIGHT A
FEMALE WHO'S LEAVING THE
MILITARY FORCE TODAY. COMING
BACK- IS A DISPROPORTION BY THE
WAY VETERANS WHO. SUFFER
DISABILITY COMING BACK FROM
AFGHANISTAN COMING BACK FROM
IRAQ. WE SAY YOU KNOW. MADAM
YOU ARE NOT ENTITLED TO THIS
PREFERENCE AS YOU WOULD BE IN
THIRTY NINE OTHER STATES- IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR THE FIFTY
OTHER STATES. BECAUSE YOU'VE
GOT TO WAIT UNTIL THE RATIO IS
EQUAL. DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME
I THINK WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE
THEIR SERVICE PROVIDE PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS THE SAME RIGHT AS WE
PROVIDE THE GOVERNMENT-
GOVERNMENT PLAYERS. BUT IF I
MAY I MEAN. THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS DOES POINT OUT. THAT
THIS ISN'T JUST A MATTER OF
SPECULATION BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE HAVE BEEN- FEDERAL AND
STATE CASES FEDERAL CASES. THAT
HAVE INVALIDATED THESE
VOLUNTARY VETERANS PREFERENCES
ON THE BASIS OF THE ADVERSE
IMPACT. THE AND IT YEAH I'M
SORRY GO AHEAD IT IS SO BY MY
CONCERN IS THAT- I I'M- NOT AS
FAMILIAR- IN TERMS OF WHAT- HOW
THIS IS- OTHER STATES HAVE
AVOIDED- THESE FINDINGS OF-
HAVE AN ADVERSE IMPACT TO
INVALIDATE THE BONTA BURKE
VETERANS PREFERENCES IN OTHER
STATES BUT- MINUTE IT DOES.
HERE TO SUPPORT THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENT BUT I AM
QUITE CONFIDENT THAT IF IT IS A
CHALLENGE THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
BONTA- MUCH LIKE THE OTHER
THIRTY. NINE ATTORNEYS GENERAL
IN THE U. S. ATTORNEY GENERAL
WOULD SUCCESSFULLY DEFEND. I
THANK YOU SPATH. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SENATOR ACTUALLY
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS YOU'RE
DOING- WITH THIS BILL I
STARTED- ACTUALLY GOT
POLITICALLY INVOLVED DURING MY
COLLEGIATE YEARS AS A- COMBAT
VETERAN WHO SURVIVED TWO
DEPLOYMENTS- PERSHING. FOR
VETERANS ADVOCACY AND IN SUCH
THINGS AS OF THIS FRANKLY I
FIND IT APPALLING THAT THE
OPPOSITION EVEN HAS THE
AUDACITY TO TRY TO MAKE THIS IS
AN ISSUE- THAT IT'S UNFAIR.
WHAT'S UNFAIR IS FOR THEM TO
WHINE AND COMPLAIN THAT OTHERS
WHO DIDN'T HAVE THE GUTS TO
SIGN THE DOTTED LINE. SHOULD
GET THE SAME TREATMENT AS THOSE
THAT DID. I IMPLORE YOU ON WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AND I'D LIKE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR. AND HELP MOVE THIS
FORWARD. OR VETERANS CITED
DOTTED LINE. REGARDLESS OF
THEIR BACKGROUND BECAUSE IN THE
MILITARY WE DON'T CARE ABOUT
THAT. IT'S NOT ABOUT WHO YOU
ARE AND WHERE YOU COME FROM AND
ALL THAT OTHER NONSENSE IT'S
ABOUT BEING AMERICANS AND
SERVING A COSTS. AND PROTECTING
THE FREEDOM FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLAIN AND WHINE. I LIKE
TO HELP YOU IN THIS ENDEAVOR IF
YOU WOULD SO SHE'S DEFINITELY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS IN THE GOOD
SENATOR- MANY OF OUR MILITARY
MEMBERS JOIN UP WHEN THEY
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL. AND
THEY'RE TRAINED AND CONDITIONED
BY THE MILITARY. WHEN THEY GET
OUT TWO TO FOUR YEARS LATER OR
IN MY CASE NINE YEARS LATER.
THEY HAVE TO MAKE THE
TRANSITION AND IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT THAT'S WHY WE HAVE SO
MANY HOMELESS VETERANS THEY
CAN'T GET JOBS THEY COULDN'T
TRANSITION THEY COULDN'T CHANGE
IT TO CIVILIAN LIFE THIS BILL
HELPS TREMENDOUSLY. AND AS FAR
AS WOMEN VETERANS GO PER CAPITA
WOMEN VETERANS HAVE A 65%
HIGHER SUICIDE RATE PER CAPITA.
SO THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY HAVING
EVEN MORE PROBLEMS TRANSITION
IN GETTING A JOB TAKING CARE OF
THEIR CHILDREN OR FUTURE-CHILDREN- SO THIS BILL.
DEFINITELY HELPS THIS BILL WILL
SAVE LIVES AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TO BE PLACED AS A CO
AUTHOR. I THANK THE MEMBER
FAMILY MEMBER DALY. OR SO ONE.
I WANT TO ENDORSE THIS QUALITY
BILL THAT CENTER- BURKE IS
BROUGHT TO US IT MAKES GREAT
SENSE HE MAKES A GREAT CASE FOR
THE BILL. AND- I WAS WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL MAKES CLEAR THE
PREFERENCE CANNOT BE USED AS A
PRETEXT INTENTIONALLY
DISCRIMINATE DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST OTHER APPLICANTS. THE
BILL WILL CLARIFY THE
EXERCISING SUCH A PREFERENCE
WOULD NOT VIOLATE STATE OR
LOCAL ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAWS.
VERY WELL CRAFTED BILL AND I
SALUTE CENTER ON BURKE FOR IT.
ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS A SENATE AMBERG WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE. NO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION. AND I
WILL ALLRIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO CLARIFY FOR THE RECORD. THAT
MANY EMPLOYERS HAVE A VETERAN
HIRING PROGRAM SAID FOR MANY
THAT AN APPLICANT WITH A
MILITARY BACKGROUND IS AN
ATTRACTIVE POTENTIAL HIGHER.
AND I DON'T WANT TO AMPLIFY THE
INTERPRETATION THAT IT'S
NECESSARILY DISCRIMINATORY OR
ILLEGAL TO HIRE OF VETERANS
THAT BEING SAID THE LAW HASN'T
BEEN UPDATED FOR A VERY LONG
TIME AND TIME AND THE INTENT OF
YOUR BILL IS A QUITE CLEAR. I
DO UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT
BEING MADE BY THE BILL'S
SUPPORTERS AND I HOPE WHERE THE
OPPOSITION OFFERS HELPFUL
SUGGESTIONS THAT SAID YOU WOULD
LOOK AT THEM. AND- SO- THIS
BILL DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND WE DID HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND TO AND IF
I COULD HAVE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ DID WRONG. SENATE BILL SIX
SIX FIVE BY UMBERG. MOVED BY
MATHIS SECOND BOERNER HORVATH
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- WHEN AYE IRWIN
AYE VOEPEL. THE BILL ONLINE
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI DALY HI DALY
ONLINE FRAZIER FRAZIER II
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MURATSUCHI.
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
RAMOS ALMOST AYE SALAS SALAS HI
SMITH. SMITH HI. ALL RIGHT AND
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CENTERS ARE ALL
RIGHT AND- WE DO HAVE A FEW
MEMBERS THAT HAVE NOT YET
REGISTERED THEIR VOTE SO I
WOULD ASK AGAIN THAT THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR CONSENT IN THE TWO BILLS
THAT ARE. OKAY BELLS.
BOERNER HORVATH HI
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
SALAS. TôI. YES PLEASE FOR THE
OTHER BILLS. BUT PRESS A MEMBER
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY EIGHT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH HI. NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS SALAS HI.
RIGHT AND THAT'S EVERYBODY OUR
RIGHTS AND WE WILL BE
ADJOURNING THIS MEETING OF.
VETERANS AND MILITARY COMMITTEE.
HELLO.